all right courts in recess he allegedly
can only see one of his girlfriends
every 90 days and then the second 90
days he can see the other girlfriend and
so on but he can't see both them at the
same time okay being in jail or prison
is not being in a luxury resort where
you can see whoever you want whenever
you want however you want in whatever
conditions you want I will say he should
consider himself fortunate that he can
see either one of them at any you know
under the circumstances of the very
serious charges filed against him in
this case alone sex trafficking Rico
rack which is racketeering influence
Corrupt Organizations Act the these are
serious charges and you know he he he
also made an argument about his medical
condition that he's feeling stressed
well most people in prison do feel
stress so if you if you don't want to
feel stress in prison the best way is
not to commit any crimes or not to do
acts which could be considered crimes so
do I have no sympathy for mr. Kelly my
sympathy is for the victims who were
very concerned about today concern that
he might be released and they're going
to be very relieved when I tell them
that
BHEL motion was denied it's not just
that he's upset about not being able to
see his girlfriend's so mr. Kelly lives
with two women these are his family and
the rules of the jail say that your
family can visit but their archaic rules
they say that your wife your husband
your mother your father your sister your
brother your kids can can visit but your
domestic partner isn't covered in the
rules your girlfriends aren't covered in
the rules so these are effectively his
domestic partners and and come on it's
2019 they should be able to visit them
I don't think that mr. Kelly's being
treated fairly I think that he should be
out he's not a flight risk there's no
evidence that he's a flight risk the
government made some reference during
2008 he did something to obstruct I
don't know what they're talking about we
haven't seen it there's no evidence that
he would obstruct it's just I think that
people are just afraid to do what we
think is the right thing here which is
damn free on bond he's presumed innocent
never been convicted of any charge it'd
be perfectly happy to be on some form of
detention in his kind of mininum in
Chicago where he can work on the case
but the judges ruled and and we respect
the judge's ruling